hey don't forget to check out our
exclusive shirts at anime uproar dot-com
including Eskin or praise the Sun Mele
Otis filled a wrath demon king meliodas
all hailed the King and many more all
the designs are exclusive originals made
by Pro manga artist Cuusoo mati and
every sure you buy help support this
channel
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the latest
shocking developments in the seven
deadly sins story before we get into
that I just want to let everyone know
that the new season of the seven deadly
sins anime has just been announced for
fall of 2019 that means that we will be
watching seven that these sins season
three the real one not the one that
flicks is calling season three as early
as October of 2019 which is amazing and
much sooner than I was expecting I will
talk about all the details about the new
season at the end of this video so stick
around for that and if you want to stay
up-to-date on all the latest news just
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime out drawer whenever we get
breaking news but we don't have time to
make a whole video we will make sure to
tweet about it and also post about it on
Instagram so following us is the easiest
way to stay up-to-date you can find the
links to both our Twitter and Instagram
in the description if you enjoyed this
type of content and you want to see more
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell and now let's
talk about the shocking and potentially
tragic developments that we just saw in
the manga there will of course be manga
spoilers in this video we are talking
about the manga so please proceed with
caution you have been warned as chapter
307 begins we are back in Leonys King
bara says that yes the holy war is over
even if it's only for the time being
this statement is interesting to me it
implies that even though the fight with
the demon king is over the holy war
itself may not be over for good this
also reminds me of Ludo Chell and how he
had said that defeating the demon king
is just the first small step in ending
the holy war for good implying that the
major conflict in the series may not be
quite over yet we see that now after the
holy war has seemingly ended the people
Leonys are struggling as they grieve
their loss isn't plan to rebuild the
kingdom we then get some light-hearted
and heartwarming scenes of Gil Thunder
waking up and having a humorous
back-and-forth with House agree amore
Margaret and Veronica personally I liked
seeing these characters that we've grown
to care about over the years interacting
with each other especially since we
haven't seen
very much of them in the most recent
arcs and that makes sense because these
characters don't have the power to
compete with any of the most recent
villains but still it was really good to
see them now we also saw Dreyfuss and
Hendrickson bonding in the aftermath of
the holy war and talking about their
middle-aged lives so that was pretty
neat and humorous then we see probably
the single most underrated girl in the
seven deadly sins Jericho hanging out
and talking to Ghia here for some reason
Gia's brother Zeile is referred to as
Dale even in the official translation
but I'm assuming that this is just a
misprint because we all know that Dale
is the name of Gihon zeals late father
these characters are soon joined by a
human-sized Matrona which was very cool
to see and also the fairies get Harada
and Laura
and they are all just kind of hanging
out and preparing to celebrate their
victory in the holy war after that we
shift focus to Hawk who appears to be
hiding from everyone and pretending that
he's just a normal Pig we know that Hawk
was acting weird in the last few
chapters and in this chapter it is
revealed that Hawk has been acting so
weird because he finally realized that
he really was weaker than everyone else
and that he was useless in the battle
compared to the sins but I don't know
about you but to me this seems like a
weird time for him to be thinking
something like that especially since
just a few chapters ago Hawk bravely
distracted the demon king long enough
for Deanna and bond to strike the final
blow now the oldest and bond proceeded
to calm Hawk down and they assure him
that the fact that he is weak but still
chooses to take risks to help his
friends means that he is truly brave
bánh mì Leona's then begin to sing the
lullaby that Hawks brother Wilde used to
sing to him back in purgatory and
although Hawk doesn't recognize the song
he suddenly begins to cry like a lot as
in snot is flowing out of his nose and
it's pretty gross but also heartwarming
bond meliodas
and Hawk then joined the others to mark
the grand opening of the new bore hat
bar where everyone is already drinking
and celebrating and having a great time
in this light-hearted scene which is a
stark contrast to the last few arcs we
see that Maya is apparently a weepy
drinker and we see King once again in
his new form serving the Boer hats
guests
according to get holiday king looks so
gallant and man
in his new for bond and meliodas
eventually leaved a party and head
outside where a major reveal is thrown
at us right at the very end of the
chapter we learned at meliodas cannot
stay here much longer and that he will
be leaving us soon
this must be related to what the demon
king said about meliodas not being able
to remain inside the mortal plane now
that his original power has awakened
although we still don't know why exactly
millie Otis can't stay in the mortal
plane and where exactly he will have to
go based on the demon king we can assume
that he will be trapped in purgatory but
that's just an educated guess at this
point now let's suppose for a moment
that the story will really end with
meliodas being forced to leave the
mortal plane and abandon all his friends
including bond and of course leave the
love of his life Elisabeth behind so
much of this story has been a journey
towards meliodas finally finding a way
to break the curse so that he can be
happy with Elizabeth in much of bonds
character arc also focused on the
development of his friendship with
meliodas in bonds decision to go into
purgatory in order to find malleolus for
such a pivotal moment in the growth of
bonds character the idea that after
everything we've been through with these
characters in d:n meliodas will simply
have to leave everything behind just
doesn't make sense to me especially
since we're talking about a shounen
series and not some tragic dark fantasy
to me this plot point with meliodas
being forced to leave feels like the
setup of a new arc rather than a
satisfactory ending for the story the
only way that I can see the story
actually ending with meliodas leaving is
if it turns out that a sequel series is
going to happen at some point kind of
like a 7 Deadly Sins Shippuden that way
finding a way to bring malleolus back
can become the first major arc of that
sequel series and doing a sequel rather
than simply moving into another arc
right away would allow the manga con
acaba suzuki to take a break if he needs
one before continuing the story we'll
have to wait and see of course the story
could just end here or there could be
more arcs to come and the epilogue
titles for the last few chapters were
just a tease or we could get a sequel at
some point in the future or there might
be some other form of continuation like
a spin-off that focuses on a different
character maybe Arthur who we are led to
believe is still dead but I'm skeptical
that he is really dead back in August of
2018 NACA busts
Sukie said that the series would end in
about a year and about 40 volumes
altogether so do we still have more of
the story to go or was that just a guess
on his part and it might actually be
ending sooner it's really hard to tell
right now
either way I'm extremely curious to find
out how all of this will end up and
please let me know what you guys think
is going to happen in the future we'll
dimana end very soon
or will there be more arcs or are we
going to see some form of sequel or
spin-off let me know down in the
comments now let's talk about the fact
that the next season of the seven deadly
sins anime has been announced for fall
of 2019 so most likely in October of
2019 we are going to be seeing the next
season that means meliodas assault mode
versus Eskin or the one the memories of
the holy war arc the miele fight and if
the series covers everything from the
manga so far that also means that kings
new form the original demon and the
battle against the demon king are all
going to be animated very soon when I
first saw the visual for the new season
I was skeptical because I wasn't
expecting it to come so soon especially
since we had to wait four years between
seasons 1 and 2 but both Japanese news
sources and Western news sources are
reporting that 7 Deadly Sins season 3
will be called wrath of the gods and it
will be premiering in Japan in fall of
2019 the official nanatsu no taizai
Twitter account wrote that during this
season the story will reach its climax
implying that the season may indeed
cover everything we've seen so far in
the manga other news include that the
season will be animated by a new studio
instead of a-1 pictures the new season
will be animated by Studio Dean the same
studio that made kono Suba and there
will be major staff changes as well
although the major voice actors are set
to return I know that some people are
definitely worried about the change of
Studios which is the same thing that
recently happened to the one punch man
anime but it is possible that the
original studio is just too busy working
on other projects so if we wanted the
same studio to animated we could end up
waiting another four years like we
waited between seasons 1 & 2 personally
I don't mind a studio change if that
means we're going to get season 3 at a
more reasonable time as long as they do
their best to animate these amazing
ARC's if they do a good job this season
could easily become a classic Shonen
anime season there is just so much
potential I am extremely excited to
start watching the new season in less
than six months and let me know how
excited you guys are down below if
you're wondering about when you might
see the new season on Netflix you might
actually have to wait a whole eight to
ten months after the season starts
airing in Japan before Netflix makes it
available so far Netflix has waited for
the entire season to finish airing
before making it available so unless
they decide to simulcast it weekly as it
comes out in Japan you're going to be
waiting quite a while also please
remember the Netflix refers to the four
episode signs of a holy war TV special
as season 2 of the anime and they refer
to the revival of the commandments as
season 3 in reality revival of the
commandments is season 2 and this new
season wrath of the gods is season 3 I
hope you guys found that information
helpful and if you enjoy these types of
videos you can leave a like to let me
know if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell because a lot more
content is coming soon be sure to follow
us on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest updates about
the seven deadly sins anime and manga
and a huge thank you to all our anime
upper patrons for supporting our work
when I especially thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
and Kela and also our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans Mayan goblin Matty Mac 239
and ace seventeen FF dB if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
opt for patron exclusive discord and
your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]